when in rome kim kardashian is stepping
out in style
that's who i am on tuesday kim
who has been vacationing in italy this
past week was spotted starting outside
of the vatican
wearing this skin-tight off-the-shoulder
dress with cutouts on both hips
paired with nude heels and these trendy
sunglasses
i know when i see something and when i
like it and when i want to be involved
in the reality star's journey to the
catholic church didn't stop there
kim was joined by several of her friends
including her assistant tracy romulus
supermodel kate moss and kate's 18 year
old daughter lila grace
inside kim and kate were covered up
snapping a photo of them together
wearing long black leather jackets to
adhere to the church's dress code
kim also posted a photo on her insta
story of the iconic art
and even one of the nuns entering the
confessional booth
like it was so so so
so amazing the skim's founder also
shared a group photo with her pals
inside the church
commemorating the most incredible
experience they had touring vatican city
kim then traveled the streets with her
glam squad making her way to the trevi
fountain
in this brown mini dress channeling
anita ekberg
in the 1961 italian classic la dolce
vita
kim's big trip comes just a week after
the conclusion
of the keeping up with kardashians
reunion which featured some shocking
revelations
including kim opening up about her
marriage to kanye west
my marriage with kanye and my kids
was you know is so
real and lots of love and
that to me was like my first
real marriage if i asked you point blank
why did your marriage not work what
would you attribute it to
i honestly don't think i would even say
it
here on on tv but it was not like one
specific thing that happened
kim filed for divorce from kanye back in
february after
six years of marriage and although a
source previously told et that the
situation with kim and kanye
is still pretty emotional and not
completely resolved
another source adds that even if kanye
has moved on
kim always has the support of her family
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
all right guys to the best family in the
entire world
that i wouldn't want to do this with
anybody else
i love you guys